I would gut that alligator and then
climb
welcome to the final level
[Music]
so I'm going to share with you guys an
interesting story about a retired NYPD
officer named Sal De La Cruz it sounds
like a drug dealer already
wow that's profiling so he's 31 all
right uh just for some context uh he
retired at 31. how do you retire at 31.
I mean NYPD really it's just done I'm
out so yeah so at the time of his
retiring his salary was 143k a year whoa
is that height for a 31. yeah you know
that is chump change really because
think about the cost of living in New
York
plus HOA fees wow what's what's starting
salary for A1 NYPD do you know the 100 I
mean even L.A right it's like 102.95 a
year starting all these big cities are
high salary and that's what they want to
get you at like oh it's high salary but
then you gotta factor in cost of living
in in the city that you live in major
city that's why I almost joined 95
when we were looking LAPD was like 60
starting Santa Monica was like uh 90.
starting wow yeah but this was what two
thousand
I want to say nine yeah back in the day
so they have it so now it's probably way
more but back then it was still a lot
yeah so that's what he's making at the
time is retiring on top of that he ends
up after his retirement he got accused
of accepting bribes for the previous
five years whoa college is a drug dealer
while in service yeah for the last five
years of his career apparently he was
allegedly accepting bribes from a
Mexican burglary Squad what uh who he
was like homies with and he was helping
them evade arrest for their entire like
burglary career where they were
targeting
um small businesses predominantly Asian
and uh yeah that's [__] up man they
know we keep it all cash yeah they would
do robberies they would do like uh
armed robberies armed invasions and uh
three of the squad members of that
burglary ring have been arrested but the
leader went to hiding they can't find
the guy what a crooked cop did you guys
see that crooked cop uh NYPD from uh the
soft white underbelly yeah that's a
great interview yeah he just tells you
like how slowly you get more and more
corrupt like it just starts with a few
things and then later it just full blown
you're a drug dealer holy [__] and you
think it's gonna be really nuanced and
Technical but it's actually very plain
yeah like how he did everything he's
like yeah we would just bust people for
drugs and then we would make them pay us
it's very like regular they just shake
down drug dealers oh wow yeah and
sometimes they would like take the drugs
and then sell it on them yeah and he
ultimately got caught not because like
he was exposed but because he ended up
beefing it with a different cop and then
that cop ratted on him oh yeah it
happens all the time man it's like bad
apples in every profession right it's
just like in the police department it's
more magnified because now you are
the civil servant you know people
believe in you and you're given this
power I mean it happened in Chicago too
there's like this uh gang unit this Tech
unit uh that worked closely and they
would do warrants on these homes that
had drugs they would bus them take take
the drugs take the money then they'll
take a cut from the money and just
disseminate it into their group and they
started started with you know a couple
hundred then it came to a couple
thousand then it got real bold then you
know Aid you know the internal
investigators started to investigate
like what the [__] going on because
these drugs there's like hey man these
guys are coming home this is how much
money I had and all the drug dealers
were telling on them yeah because you
know they get arrested
so they're like oh yeah on the paper
it's like hey so yeah we confiscated
this x amount of money they're like wait
what I had a million yeah not a thousand
yeah I had a hundred thousand no it says
this 50
wait what it happens man or they can
just keep lying just like yeah that
could be an angle it's like training day
it is like Training Day ooh it's scary
wait so you're saying training day is a
documentary
you give certain people power and they
and they just abuse it yeah you know
have you ever witnessed like being part
of different departments yeah have you
ever witnessed another cop do something
that wasn't up to standard so uh luckily
in my 14 years as a cop all the people
that I've
been able to work with or or you know
during whatever call or crime scene or
everything all these cops were
outstanding individuals oh that's great
none of them were on that scandalous I'm
not saying does is all police
departments like that I mean the whole
police were absolutely not it's
impossible it's big though right major
cities don't they have like 10 000 or
some oh yeah outrageous numbers oh huge
it's huge yeah how many did the Chicago
Police Department have like how many how
many guys they got 12 000 people right
there Wow have you ever had an incident
where like
you like the people that you work with
was fine but you know someone in the
department and you hear like something
happen you're like him yeah what the
heck oh yeah there were guys who went
through the academy graduated got their
star got their gun went out drinking had
their pistols tucked in the back the
bouncer was like hey man you had enough
to drink you got to leave you [__]
pulls out of the pistol throws on the
[__] table make me leave like I'm a
[__] shot like stupid [__] like like
bro like what the [__] are you thinking
you're in brand new recruit you know
like just because you have a star and a
gun now it doesn't make you [__] I
don't know whoever the [__] you think
you are you know you still gotta file a
letter of law remember I was learning
about the those Marines yeah I was like
those guys probably recently graduated
boot camp because it just sounds like
I'm bulletproof take off my shirt look
how [__] cool I am because once
you're like 10 years in like this is my
job I just want to go to work and go
back home and and not all Special
Operations members are legit too there
was a time uh Bart did you ever hear
about the story about uh a bunch of
Rangers and second ranger battalion uh
robbing banks
Rangers no wow that's like the best bank
robber in the world what a squad yeah
with a squad they got us it's it's up
there in uh state of Washington it's
[__] cool though yeah they they got
together they're like dude we got this
training let's let's [__] hit them
but uh when they watch the surveillance
they saw how they were moving so
tactically yeah they're like so they the
investigators like wait these guys are
not just regular [__] troops and
start doing investigate I think I forgot
how they got caught probably something
with their license plate or something
like that but yeah it was a bunch of
[__] Rangers robbing banks up in
state of Washington yeah one of the odds
that that many Rangers would have the
same mentality to agree to do yeah you
know some Squad freaking yeah oh yeah
you know what's funny because uh when I
was in regimes like dude we got so much
room we can [__] go rob a bank
but everyone's like yeah we could but
you know it's a joke one guy that's like
yeah we just should yeah you're like
wait yeah we should you know uh when
when Tim Kennedy was in Vegas and he was
running his courses yeah
um when he was like when I was getting
my ass by everybody like he had his
whole Squad there right like his right
hand man's a seal he's special for us
whatever and I just see like his whole
Squad there and I looked at him and I
was like hey if you guys wanted like
burn Vegas down could you and all of
them without even looking at each other
like yes turn Vegas down that's the
question here
like if you needed to take over the city
like in like an hour they just all of
them like yeah I'm like
like oh okay I'm getting the [__] out of
here yeah the military poor millions of
dollars in these high-level guys yeah
yeah yeah I mean millions of dollars of
training I got my buddy in uh Team One
I'm gonna go visit soon uh today this
weekend Seal Team One and the trainings
that they sent him to I just like
[__] mind blown like you think Navy
SEAL the title is badass no the training
that you get after you join when you
make that type of unit is the the real
Ice Age oh yeah like Advanced breaching
of like Advanced sniper and then some
counterintelligence ships some of these
snipers are really
three four five even miles out that
these guys can do is that true can't
even see that far yeah I was gonna say
like through I don't know oh the
distance yeah the distance of some of
these guys who could shoot malls are
really long yeah
yeah they understand the the the dope
and mature of the Earth yeah it comes
into play yeah that's so crazy what
about you said you mentioned Counter
Intelligence yeah what does that entail
like what is when you say like spying on
certain individuals tapping their phones
breaking into the house without them
knowing planning [__] chips and
whatnot being able to there's a course
and this is no [__] that you that
they train you to evade uh being on
camera like you could you wanted one of
the uh for you to pass is for you to
enter back into the United States under
effect a fake [__] Alias oh my God
that's like the final course [__] so
cool that's [__] gangster and they
and they have so much money I would got
an alligator and then climb
did you see my face through the through
the mouth that's the [__] thing they
teach you
it's mating season so he gets bummed by
another alligator no no no no no no
welcome to the final level that's some
crazy [__] out there man that's insane
wow that's kind of fun yeah there's some
like Jason Bourne [__] and then if you
get caught is it like you Pat you you
failed the exam you can't you can't be
in it yeah I don't know how that works
but there's definitely some crazy [__]
going on that we don't know about are
you stuck in jail like this is what you
get for failing yeah they just pretend
they don't know you other than honorable
discharge what is this
foreign
[Music]